Hello, listener. This is Jason Bateman along with Will Arnett and Sean Hayes for the podcast called Smartless. If that's a place you're looking for, you found it. Congratulations. It's not a real high concept podcast. One person invites a guest. The other two don't know who that guest is. And then we chat. Here we go. Smart Lawless Smart Lars Jason, you missed this last time look what I got That's a baby Yoda?
你好，听众朋友。我是杰森·贝特曼，还有威尔·阿奈特和肖恩·海斯，欢迎收听播客《聪明无知》。如果你在找的就是这个节目，那你找到了。恭喜。这不是一个概念很高的播客。一个人邀请一个嘉宾。另外两个人不知道那个嘉宾是谁。然后我们开始聊天。我们开始吧。聪明无知 聪明无知 杰森，你上次错过了这个，看我拿到了什么。那是尤达宝宝吗？
It's a baby Yoda and there's a message on here Is that from the Mandalorian show? Yeah, this is from my friend Michael Cohen and the Cohen family, not that Michael Cohen. But look, and he recorded this. Welcome to SmartList, the best podcast in the world with my dear friend Sean Hayes.
这是尤达宝宝，上面还有一条信息。那是来自《曼达洛人》剧集里的吗？对，这是我的朋友迈克尔·科恩和科恩一家发来的，不是那个迈克尔·科恩。但是看，他还录了这个。欢迎来到《聪明无知》，世界上最好的播客，由我亲爱的朋友肖恩·海斯主持。
Jason Bateman and William Arnett. He went William. I like that he went William. Yeah, and Baby Yoda said that. So he's the voice of Baby Yoda? Yeah, could you not tell him? He sounds Latin. I didn't know Baby Yoda.
杰森·贝特曼和威廉·阿奈特。他叫了威廉。我喜欢他叫威廉。对，尤达宝宝说的。所以他是尤达宝宝的配音？对，你听不出来吗？他听起来像拉丁裔。我不知道尤达宝宝。
Actually, he is. Baby Yoda is Latin, huh? I got to watch that show. I'm developing a new show. It's Baby Yoda Nanny, and it's a nanny who works who looks after. No, it's just the doll that you leave with your kids and tell them they're watching them. Yeah. It should be noted.
其实，他就是。尤达宝宝是拉丁裔，是吧？我得去看看那个节目。我正在开发一个新节目。它是《尤达宝宝保姆》，讲的是一个保姆在照顾……不，它只是一个留给你孩子并告诉他们保姆在看着他们的玩偶。是的。应该指出的是。
Jason's haircut. Have you commented on it on a good? finally it looks good right well this is guys listen this is just rolled right out of bed it's such a thick head of hair i know it's so thick but it's a very boyish look he's got going right now isn't it it looks very boyish i know i'm trying to get respect as an adult but that's why sometimes i try to grow up my facial hair but that takes you push it cost me a year actually to grow that because you're just saying to the world hey i'm a man and respect i'm a man deal with it all right so speaking of Men, we have a man today.
杰森的发型。你们有人评论过它吗，说它很好？终于看起来不错了，对吧？好吧，这个，伙计们听着，这只是刚起床的样子，头发这么浓密。我知道，太浓密了。但这是一种非常幼稚的发型，他现在留着，不是吗？看起来非常幼稚。我知道，我正试图作为成年人赢得尊重，这就是为什么有时我试着留点面部毛发，但这需要你推一把。其实花了我一整年才留出来，因为你只是在向全世界宣布，嘿，我是一个男人，尊重我，我是一个男人，接受它吧。好吧，说到男人，我们今天有一位男士。
This is a funny man, family man, and for the next hour, he's a smartless man. Ladies and gentlemen, Adam Sandler. Adam Sandler. The one and only. I love it. I'm sorry about this. Wow, look at, now, that's a man. Look at the beer.
这是一个有趣的男人，顾家的男人，在接下来的一个小时里，他是一个聪明无知的男人。女士们先生们，亚当·桑德勒。亚当·桑德勒。独一无二的亚当·桑德勒。我太喜欢了。不好意思。哇，看，现在，那才叫个男人。看看那胡子。
It's gross. It's gross. Good to see you all. You're moving dime bags or something with a beard like that. Wow. It started off early in the. pandemic and I just kept going because I gained a lot
真恶心。真恶心。很高兴见到你们。你留着那样的胡子，是在倒卖小包毒品还是别的什么。哇。这疫情刚开始时就有了，我一直留着，因为我长了很多……
so I was covering the neck. You gained a lot of weight? Of knowledge, of knowledge. Yeah. Yeah, a lot of way. But wait, I just read a report yesterday that said belly fat is now officially, medically proven to lessen your life if you have a lot of belly fat, no matter how much other fat
所以我用来遮住脖子。你长了很多肉？知识，知识。对。对，长了很多肉。但是等等，我昨天刚好读到一篇报道，上面说如果你的腹部脂肪很多，不管你有多少其他脂肪，现在官方、医学上已经证明这会缩短你的寿命。
you have. Let's see it, Sean. Let's see it Sean and scream. You guys don't like cookies? Once a week, he brings it out. There it is. The bagel. I love it. No, who ate the cookies? What'd you call it the bagel? The bagel, yeah, squeeze the belly button together, make a circle.
让我们看看，肖恩。让我们看看肖恩并尖叫吧。你们不喜欢曲奇吗？每周一次，他把它拿出来。就是那个。百吉饼。我喜欢。不，谁吃了曲奇？你把它叫什么，百吉饼？百吉饼，对，把肚脐挤在一起，画个圆圈。
And, Adam, sometimes I say to my husband, I'll switch, I'll pucker this up, I'll go, fuck that belly, fuck that. That makes sense. It looks good. All right, so Adam, do you have a plan, aside from pushing, like a bench press or something like that? What's your plan? Is it going to be diet? Is it going to be exercise? Well, this is what I'm doing, and I just kind of started this.
而且，亚当，有时候我对我的丈夫说，我会换一下，我会把嘴撅起来，我会说，去你的肚子，去你的。这说得通。看起来不错。好吧，那么亚当，你有什么计划吗，除了推举，比如卧推或类似的事情？你的计划是什么？是要节食吗？是要锻炼吗？好吧，这就是我正在做的，我刚开始弄这个。
So at the beginning of the pandemic, my buddy was doing the eight hours a day you eat thing, the intermittent fasting. Yeah, I do that too. So I was doing that during a pandemic, but I was starting eating at like five in the afternoon. So I was going deep into the night. And then I'd wake up kind of thick. So then I got some bad information. I thought I said to him anytime and he said, yeah, you picked the hour. So I did it.
所以在疫情刚开始时，我的死党在搞一天吃八小时的那种间歇性断食。对，我也那样做。所以我疫情期间一直在那样做，但我大约下午五点才开始吃。所以我一直吃到深夜。然后我醒来时感觉胖乎乎的。接着我得到了一些糟糕的信息。我以为我问过他“随时都可以吗？”，他说，对，你自己选时间。于是我就这么做了。
He responded while. chewing i think he looks great but uh i so anyways i started again uh i just i'm trying to calm down and i'm doing one in the afternoon to around seven seven 30 i quit and then you're then you're done chewing until the next morning or afternoon yeah i true until the next one o'clock rolls around oh buddy that's so good that's a good one but i eat a lot during the six and a half hour it doesn't work for yeah it doesn't work for my body it doesn't work for me i tried doing that i was on a strictly ice cream diet but yeah you got to try it longer than a couple of days well you know what do you do well you look good well thank you i because like i said i've been doing
他一边嚼东西一边回答。我觉得他看起来状态很好，但是……嗯，所以无论如何我又开始了，嗯，我只是在努力收敛，我从下午一点左右开始吃，到七点、七点半左右收工，然后你就不吃了，然后你就停止咀嚼，直到第二天早上或下午。是的，我一直咀嚼到第二天的一点钟到来。哦，伙计，太棒了，这招真不错。但在那六个半小时里我吃得太多了。这对我没用，对，这不适合我的身体，这不适合我。我试过这样做，我曾进行过严格的冰淇淋饮食法，但是，是的，你得坚持几天以上才行。好吧，你知道，你做得怎么样？好吧，你看起来不错。谢谢，因为就像我说的，我一直在散步，我一直在锻炼，我车库里有一个我称之为“牢房健身房”的东西。杰森见过它，一团糟，但里面有哑铃和类似你自己做的简易器材。哦，里面有哑铃，还有婴儿车之类的破烂，到处都是。它看起来真像一个……我有个问题，亚当。你开宇宙飞船多久了？看起来像那样吗？看起来像个控制中心。
the walk and i've been working out and i've got this real kind of what i referred to as my jailhouse gym in my garage now jason's seen it it's a disaster but but there's weights and like homemade stuff you did oh there's weights and then there's like baby carriages and stuff and they're just crap everywhere It really looks like a... I have a question, Adam. How long have you been flying a spacecraft? Does that look like that? Looks like a control center.
这是在我家里，伙计们。我刚弄了费城……哦，哇。等等，那是什么？你为什么有……他塑料盒里有几双耐克鞋。那是勒布朗·詹姆斯的鞋。拥有这栋房子的人认识勒布朗。
This is in my house, fellas. I just got the Philadelphia. Oh, wow. Wait, what are those? Why do you have... He's got some Nike's in a plastic box. Those are LeBron James shoes. The man who owns his house knows LeBronite.
你认识这房子的主人吗？不认识。我还没见过他。他在疫情期间。所以你是租的。他搬走了。哦，你在租房。我明白了。
Do you know the man in the house? I don't. I haven't met him yet. He's pandemic. So you rent it. He leaves. Oh, you're renting. I see.
哦，哇。我两天前刚搬来。但他留下了那些鞋子，给来租房的人观赏吗？我想他只是在让我知道我不是唯一的鞋迷。他认识的名人。对，对， exatamente。等一下，等一下。
Oh, wow. I just got here two days ago. But he's left those shoes. for people to admire that are renters? I think he was just letting me know that I'm not the only shoe guy. Famous person that he knows. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Wait a second, wait a second.
亚当，我不得不问你这个，因为我从来没提过。这些年来我只见过你几次面。我们其实没那么熟。我对你极其尊敬，我觉得你太棒了，而且 hilarious。我也是。听起来好像马上要发生什么非常侮辱人的事了。不，不，不，不。
Adam, I have to ask you this because I've never bought it up. I've only met you a handful of times over the years. We don't know each other that well. I have a tremendous amount of respect for you, and I think that you're awesome and hilarious. Same thing. Sounds like something really insulting is about to happen. No, no, no, no.
我亲眼见过的最搞笑的事情之一，我引用过一千次，可能更多，是多年前你在莱特曼的节目上，他对你说——你看看你还记不记得——他对你说了什么，你上了莱特曼的节目，你说，你知道，戴夫，他说，你最近怎么样？你说，你知道，我还行，但去年我说过一些话，你对我说，你是个白痴吗？你真的把我噎得够呛，我一整年都在想这件事，就是恨自己当时没有更好的回击，所以我一直在想，我终于想出一个好的回击了。他说，好吧。然后你说，所以，再问我一遍。
One of the funniest things I've, ever witnessed, and I've quoted this a thousand times, maybe more, is years ago you were on Letterman, and he said to you, tell me if you remember this, he said to you, you came on Letterman, and you said, you know, Dave, he said, how are you doing? You said, you know, I'm doing okay, but last year I said something, and you said to me, what are you an idiot? And you really burned me, and I was thinking about it all year, just I wish I'd had a better comeback, so I've been thinking I finally have a good comeback. And he said, okay. And you said, so I, Ask me again.
于是莱特曼对你说，你是个白痴吗？你说了，不，你才是吗？你还记得吗？我有点印象，对。对。这是我最……我当时就觉得，这太绝了，真的把我镇住了。我没开玩笑。
So Letterman says to you, what are you an idiot? And you said, no, are you? Do you remember that? I kind of do, yeah. Yeah. It was one of my faith. I just thought it was such a, it really got me. I'm not kidding.
我重复了1500遍。太棒了。我以前上莱特曼节目时紧张得要命。你们，哦，上莱特曼？大脑一片空白。对，紧张得大脑一片空白。那是唯一一个能让你紧张的人。对，我大脑一片空白。
I've repeated it 1,500 times. That's amazing. I used to get so nervous on Letterman. You guys, oh, did Letterman? Blackout. Yeah, Blackout nerves. That was the one guy that got you nervous. Yeah, I get blackout.
对，真的。每个脱口秀都是。莱特曼，因为我高中时就是看着他的节目长大的，觉得他是所有人里最棒的一个。对，真的。我以前总是站在那个舞台侧幕，Biff会说，哦，好吧，好吧，要上场了。然后我就会开始觉得，天哪。我的整个脑袋都在旋转，走出去的时候感觉自己快要晕倒了。然后你亲眼看到戴夫。
Yeah, for sure. Every talk show. Letterman, just from growing up. up in high school and thinking he was the best of them all. Yeah, for sure. I used to be on the side of that stage and Biff would like, oh, okay, okay, it's coming. And I'd start going, holy. Like, my whole head would spin and I feel like I was going to faint the whole time walking out. And then you'd see Dave in person.
你会想，哦，天哪，他在那儿。太压抑了。对，对。现在，这种感觉对你来说还存在吗？我是说，你现在把自己放在侧幕，准备明天去上类似脱口秀的节目。对。你会不会，就像，你无法摆脱那种感觉，它将永远是你的一部分，对吧？你只是学会了如何控制它，其实也没控制得多好。我整个职业生涯从开始时——我17岁就开始做单口喜剧之类的，我也有那种奇怪的毛病，就是希望上台前永远不要接这个演出，然后我就开始恐慌、眩晕，忘掉所有的台词。呃，我注意到其他人都笑得很开心，过得很愉快。
You're like, oh, my God, there he is. It was so overwhelming. Yeah, yeah. Now, does that exist for you at all anymore? I mean, you put yourself in the wings right now, about to go on for a talk show like tomorrow. Yeah. Do you, like, you can't shake. that it's always going to be a part of you right you have you just learned how to manage it not that great i my whole career from starting i did stand up when i was 17 and stuff and and i had that same weird thing where i wish i never took the gig right before and i started paddicking and spinning i forget all my lines uh i noticed everyone else was like laughing and having a good time
我就想，哦，天哪，其他人都准备好了。然后，呃，难得有几次我会对自己说，在白天的时候我会对自己说，别那样做，别搞那种会让你恐慌的把戏，克服它，现在就把这个克服掉。然后你不会质疑自己吗，为什么，为什么？因为我经历着完全相同的事情，然后我会想，我们为什么要这么做，我为什么会选择这个？对，对，我们所有人都在纳闷，我们总是会想，你为什么要选择这个？相信我，这种想法经常出现。说得真好，对，留下来，威尔手里有大约三个这种问题。不，但，但，但这是一个很好的观点，亚当，我觉得最酷的是，你实际上有时会利用你的紧张情绪，你甚至可以在那样的时刻看出来，你把它转化为你的优势，这让你变得非常……平易近人，因为你没有在装腔作势，你不是在扮演一个不同的角色，你就是你自己，你在那方面非常真实，这太棒了，就像，对，对，对。你他妈就是很紧张，因为你在上莱特曼的节目，你本该如此。我很紧张，但你今天对这场扯淡不紧张。我很紧张，当然。我是说，我，我其实挺喜欢的，我听过那些节目，都棒极了，拜托。太棒了。
i'm like oh my god everyone else is ready and and then uh then rare occasions i'll go to myself in the daytime i'll go don't do that don't do do that thing where you panic just just overcome that now get over that and then don't you question yourself like why why because i i go through the exact same thing and i'm like why are we why do i why did i choose this yeah yeah we all wonder we're always like why did you choose this believe me it comes up a lot that's a good one yeah stick around and will's got like three of them no but but but it's a good point like adam i think what's cool is you actually kind of sometimes you use your nerves you can see it even in an instance like that you use it to your advantage and it makes you very um accessible because you're not trying to put on you're not a different character as you are who you are you're very authentic in that way which is great like yeah yeah yeah you're fucking nervous because you're on letterman you should be i'm nervous but you aren't you weren't nervous for this bullshit today i was nervous sure i mean i i i liked it though i listened to the episodes they're all great come on It's excellent.
而且我很高兴能来到这里。而且我不知道。我和你们一样。我对你做的每一个举动都抱有同感。你会想，伙计，难道我还没证明过自己吗？为什么我他妈的还要试图证明自己？我他妈的为什么在这儿？又来了。
And I was psyched to be here. And I don't know. I'm the same way as you guys. I'm the same way of every move you make. You go, didn't I already prove myself, dude? Why the hell am I trying to prove myself? What the fuck am I here? Here we go again.
对，没错。唯一可能发生的事就是搞砸。你知道，但是威尔刚才提到的那种属于你的特质，它是那么平易近人，那么善良，那么真实，那么诚实，那么有人情味。一直都是这样的吗？还是你觉得，随着你变得难以置信的成功，生活变得更加轻松，它现在变得甚至更好了？因为你基本上已经赢了。你变得更随和了吗？或者，你知道，就像有些人，我确信你也和他们合作过，就像我一样，人们在成功之后实际上变得刻薄和自以为是。你似乎走相反的方向。
Yeah, exactly. The only thing that can happen is it can go bad. You know, but that quality that Will's talking about that you have, that's so personalable and it's so kind and so authentic and so honest and so human. Has it always been like that? Or do you think that it's gotten even? better now that you are incredibly successful and some of the ease has come into your life because you've basically won. Have you gotten even nicer? Or, you know, like some people, I'm sure you've
是的。你们大家看起来也都一样。这就好比我，我觉得我年轻时，作为喜剧演员我不知道自己在做什么。作为演员我也不知道自己在做什么。我有点毫无章法。我觉得那时我更具攻击性一些，因为我想我太渴望成功了，你知道，我想工作，或者我想要我他妈的任何东西。我可能在生自己的气，气自己不够优秀。我在二十出头的时候更有攻击性一些。然后我开始改变，到我大约28岁、30岁的时候，我开始冷静下来，能够稍微放松一点了。
worked with as I have, people actually get mean and entitled when they get successful. You've seemed to have gone the other way. Yeah. You guys all seem the same also. It's like I had a, I think when I was young, I didn't know what I was doing as a comedian. I didn't know what I doing as an actor. I was a little all over the place. I think I was a little more aggressive back then because I guess I wanted this so bad, you know, I wanted to work or I wanted whatever the hell I wanted. And I probably was mad at myself for not being great. I was a little more aggressive in my early 20s. And then I started going, by the time I was like 28, 30, I started calming down and being able to just relax
但这花了一些时间。就像科林，你们认识科林·奎恩，对吧？对，喜剧演员。太搞笑了。我觉得他是最伟大的喜剧演员之一。他某种程度上，当我上纽约大学时，经常担任节目的主持，他会在我的演出结束后跟我聊天。
a little more. But it took a while. Like Colin, you guys know Colin Quinn, right? Yeah, comedian. Hilarious. I think he's one of the greatest comedians. And he kind of, when I went to NYU, used to emce the shows and he would talk to me after
我觉得他们以前雇佣我的原因是我能带观众来。所以他们，即使我当时没那么好，有个叫“纸月亮”的地方，我经常能从纽约大学带观众过去。科林经常说，白天我们聊天时，你相处起来要搞笑得多。你在台上时在搞一些奇怪的把戏。
my shows. I think the reason they used to hire me is I used to bring a crowd. So they, even though I wasn't that good, there was this place called the Paper Moon and I used to bring a crowd so they used to from NYU. And Colin used to say, it's so much funnier hanging out when we're talking in the daytime. You're just, you're doing something weird up to you.
你并不是真的在做你自己。我以前总是试图对自己说，好吧，我得更像我自己一点。然后我就会立刻恐慌，开始搞别的东西。我就是不……我想我当时对自己做自己感到不自在。后来花了好一阵子才终于能安下心来，接受偶尔得不到笑声，但依然坚持下去的那种状态。你上纽约大学是学戏剧的吗？还是学表演或者……
You're not really being yourself. And I used to try to go, okay, I got to be more myself. And then I would just panic right away and start doing something else. I just didn't, I guess I wasn't comfortable with being myself. And then it took a while to get to sit in it and just be okay with not getting a laugh and but plowing through and that kind of stuff. Did you go to NYU for drama? or for acting or...
对，对，我上了斯特拉斯堡戏剧学院。我也是。对。好吧，我有位教子现在也正在去纽约上提什艺术学院，他不仅要经历戏剧课、喜剧课所有这些东西，他还得经历音乐剧课。所以当我第一次看你扮演“歌剧男”时，
Yeah, yeah, I went to Strasbourg. Same. Yeah. Okay, so I have a godson who's also going to New York right now to Tish and he not only has to go through drama classes and comedy and all that stuff, but he has to go through musical theater classes. And so when I saw you do Opera Man for the first time,
那是我见过的最搞笑的角色之一。我就想，卧槽，亚当·桑德勒真的会唱歌。然后你就会拿出吉他开始唱，总是那么搞笑。所以请告诉我你在大学里演过音乐剧，因为在我看来那将是世界上最搞笑的事情之一。我在纽约大学试镜了所有东西。我什么都没得到。
which is one of the funniest characters I've ever seen. I was like, holy shit, Adam Sandler can really sing. And then you would bring out the guitar and sing like, it's always hilarious. So please tell me you did musical theater in college because in my mind that would be one of the funniest things in the world. I auditioned for everything at NYU. I didn't get anything.
没有？哦，我想看你演《约瑟的神奇彩衣》。或者类似的东西。不过我小时候演过《雾都孤儿》。我演过《雾都孤儿》。我演过，他们给了一个角色名字。我其实没有……其实没什么，我有两句台词，他们说，你是，我想是查理·贝茨。他们说，你是查理·贝茨。
You didn't? Oh, I want to see you do Technicolor Dreamcoat. Or something. I did as a kid, though, I was in Oliver. I was in Oliver. I did, I played, they named a guy. I didn't really, there wasn't really, I had two lines and they said, you're, I think Charlie Bates. They said, you're Charlie Bates.
我说，对，我是查理·贝茨。我其实挺想演道奇的，对吧？然后他们说，嗯，你不是他。你是查理·贝茨。哦，天哪。你会是个很棒的道奇。我也这么觉得。你有一两个顺手牵羊的小技能，对吧？
And I was like, yeah, I'm Charlie Bates. I kind of wanted to be the Dodger, right? And they were like, well, you're not him. You're Charlie Bates. Oh, God. You'd be a great dodger. I thought so, too. You got a picket pocket or two, right?
对，对，对，对。那《考斯比一家》里的斯密迪呢？对。那是你的第一个角色吗？那不是你的第一份工作。我做过的第一件事是《阿波罗剧院之秀》。我说了单口喜剧。我说了五分钟，对，我当时没那么好，但我得到了……
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. How about Smitty on the Cosby show? Yeah. Was that your first? That's not your first role. My first thing I ever did was Showtime at the Apollo. I did stand-up. I did five minutes, yeah, and I wasn't that great, but I got...
告诉我，比如你讲的第一个笑话是什么。如果你愿意的话，我可以告诉你我的。好吧，当年对我管用的那个笑话是这样的，那是我听我父亲对我母亲说的一句话，但我把它拿来用了，假装是发生在我自己身上。我说我坐出租车来这里的，司机在路上撞死了一只狗，说他不是用车撞的狗，而是下车把它给捅死了。那是我的大招，保证能让人笑出来。这个笑话之所以发生，是因为我母亲——我的母亲，他们当时在车里，我母亲说，那个男人，呃，我父亲说这家伙开车撞死了一条狗，
Tell me, like, the first joke you ever told her. And if you'd like, I could tell you mine. Okay, well, the one that worked for... me back then was it was something I heard my father say to my mother but I and I used it and pretended to happen to me I said I was driving up here in a cab and the driver killed a dog on the way said he didn't hit the dog with the car you got out and stabbed it that was my big that was my guaranteed lap and that happened because my mother my mother was they were in the car and my mother goes the man uh my father said this guy killed the dog driving the other
我母亲说，怎么回事？他撞的吗？他说，不，他捅死的。然后我就想，天哪，这个挺不错的。肖恩，你的呢？哦，我太糟糕了。我远没有你那么有才华，也没有你那么搞笑。我太糟糕了。这些家伙都知道那个我不愿重复的笑话。但另一个是这样的，而且很长，所以你不能……它大约有20秒长，好吧？所以，作为一个笑话来说它挺长的。所以我会说，你知道，嗯，他们说在火星上，大气层大约是95%的二氧化碳和5%的氧气。所以我猜有一天我们在那里生活时，我们会呼吸类似这样空气。然后他们没有为那个笑话笑。
my mother goes, what happened? He hit it? And he goes, no, he stabbed at you. And so I went, oh, God, that's a pretty good one. What's yours, Sean? Oh, I was terrible. I was nowhere near as talented or funny as you are. I was horrible. These guys know the one that I won't repeat. But the other one was, and it's long, so you can't, it's like, it's like 20 seconds long, okay? So, it's just long for a joke. So I would go, you know, uh, they say on Mars, the atmosphere is like 95% carbon dioxide and 5% oxygen. So I imagine one day when we live there, we'll breathe something like this. And they didn't laugh at that.
他们从来没笑过。我哭着走下台。那个很扎实。你讲的时候把手指竖起来了吗？我也喜欢那个。那个不错。亚当，关于那个被喜剧演员丹尼斯·米勒发掘的事是怎么回事？是在阿波罗剧院发生的吗？
They never laughed. I left crying. That's solid. Did you hold your finger up when you did it? I like that, too. That's a good one. Adam, what about this discovered by comedian Dennis Miller thing? Did that happen at the Apollo?
我无法想象。你知道吗？其实是这样的，我上纽约大学时就开始说单口了。然后丹尼斯并没有真正发掘我。他只是把我的情况告诉了洛恩·迈克尔斯。他说有个很有趣的年轻小伙子。但我年轻时，我和安东尼·奎恩的儿子洛伦佐一起上学。他在我的表演班里。
I can't imagine. You know what? It was, so I did stand up when I went to NYU. And then Dennis didn't really discover me. He just told Lauren Michaels about me. He said there's a young kid who's funny. But when I was young, I went to school with Anthony Quinn's son, Lorenzo. He was in my acting class.
他把我的情况告诉了比尔·考斯比。然后我得到了引荐，认识了他们那里的选角导演，名叫巴里·莫斯。你们还记得巴里·莫斯吗？我以前经常去试镜……
And he told Bill Cosby about me. And I got an introduction to the casting agent over there whose name was Barry Moss. Do you guys remember Barry Moss? I used to cast him. a lot of stuff back in the day. Right? So he got me an audition and I played Smitty on four episodes while I was going to NYU. That was my first job.
以前经常去。对吧？所以他帮我安排了一次试镜，我在上纽约大学的同时在四集里扮演了斯密迪。那是我的第一份工作。
And that was big probably. I mean, Cosby Show was enormous. It was the biggest show on the planet. It was incredible. And that's where I developed the whole spinning thing right before going on. I was spinning like, oh, my God, I got six lives. I've got to choke so badly. And I don't know.
那可能挺轰动的。我是说，《考斯比秀》太庞大了。那是星球上最大的节目。太不可思议了。也就是在那里，我养成了上台前疯狂打转的习惯。我转着圈想，天哪，我有六条命。我非得糟糕地搞砸不可。而且我不知道。
I became friends with Malcolm, though. He used to calm me down. He'd be like, you got this, man. Yeah, he's such a good guy. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Wow. So then how long after that did SNL happen? How old were you when that happened?
不过我和马尔科姆成了朋友。他过去常常让我平静下来。他会说，你能行的，伙计。对，他是个很好的人。对，对，对。哇。那之后过了多久周六夜现场就找你了？发生那事时你多大？
SNL happened when I was 23. I moved out to, I graduated NYU, and then I moved to L.A. And I was living out in Van Nuys. And then... Beautiful. Gorgeous family. Yeah, yes.
我去周六夜现场时23岁。我搬到……我从纽约大学毕业，然后搬到了洛杉矶。我住在范奈斯。然后……太美了。美丽的家庭。对，是的。
Right on the water. Beautiful. And I live with four guys from... from NYU also. And then somehow I got Saturday Night Live and moved back. Well, did you go and audition in L.A.? Did Lauren come out? Chicago.
就在水边。太美了。我和另外四个来自纽约大学的家伙住在一起。然后不知怎么的我就进了《周六夜现场》并搬了回去。好吧，你是去洛杉矶试镜的吗？洛恩来过吗？芝加哥。
Chicago. When I auditioned, it was me and Chris Rock and Dana Gould and a couple other guys. At Second City or? At the Chicago Improv. Oh, it's Chicago Improv. Yeah, and then I remember Lauren was there and Smigel, Robert Smigel, was there.
芝加哥。我试镜时，现场有我和克里斯·洛克、达娜·古尔德还有其他几个人。在第二城剧院还是？在芝加哥即兴剧场。哦，是芝加哥即兴剧场。对，然后我记得洛恩在那儿，斯米格尔，罗伯特·斯米格尔也在那儿。
And Marcy. declined a couple of others. And Chris Rock got it immediately after the show. And me and Rock know each other since we're like 17 also. And so I saw Lorne run over to Rock and I was like, oh man, okay, he's got it. I'm out. And then I was flying home and no one talked to me. And I was flying home. And remember on the planes you used to put a credit card in it was like 25 bucks a minute and stuff? Right. Right. So I was scared to use that because I knew my My father would kill me for wasting money, but I was just flying and flying. And I was like, I got to call my agent, man.
还有玛西·克莱恩和其他几个人。然后克里斯·洛克在演出结束后立刻就被录用了。我和洛克从17岁左右就认识了。所以我看到洛恩朝洛克跑过去，我就想，哦，天哪，好吧，他被录用了。我没戏了。然后我正在坐飞机回家，没有人跟我说话。我在飞往回家的路上。还记得以前在飞机上你要把信用卡塞进去，大概是25美元一分钟之类的吗？没错。没错。所以我不敢用那个，因为我知道我父亲会因为我浪费钱而宰了我，但我一直在飞啊飞。然后我想，我得给我经纪人打电话，伙计。
So I put the credit card in and he called and I said, did they say anything? They liked you. They thought some of your writing was good. I said, oh, okay. And what's that being? They were like, well, they want, maybe want you as a writer. And I said, what do you mean? I think I was like insane.
所以我把信用卡塞进去，他接了电话，我说，他们说什么了吗？他们喜欢你。他们觉得你写的一些东西挺不错的。我说，哦，好吧。那结果是怎样？他们就说，嗯，他们想要，也许想让你当个编剧。我说，你什么意思？我觉得我当时简直疯了。
And I was like, I want to be a, but I want to be a star. I love the guy next to you on the plane probably. It's just like, oh, boy. Yeah, this guy wants to be a star. Because you can't talk quietly on a plane. But I want to be a star! Get in line, buddy. Get in line.
我就像，我想当个，但我想当个明星。你可能挨着飞机上另一个乘客。就像，哦，天哪。对，这家伙想当明星。因为你在飞机上没法小声说话。但我想要当明星！排队去吧，伙计。排队去吧。
We all knew. Yeah, man, I don't know. So eventually I got hired as a writer. A writer for what, like a year and then on camera? Yeah, I did. It was a thing called writer-feature player. And me and Spade and Schneider had that. And you would do the, I'm sure you guys all know this stuff,
我们都懂。是的，伙计，我不知道。所以最终我被雇为编剧。编剧，比如干了一年然后转到幕前？是的，我干了。那有个头衔叫编剧兼特色演员。我和斯佩德、施耐德都有这个头衔。然后你会做——我确信你们大家都懂这些东西，
but you would write for everyone else and then give yourself a line, like, as a delivery guy and try to get on and score and, you know, and you'd score after 10 shows, they started going, all right, that guy's okay. Let's give him a couple of lines. Right, gotcha. You used to see that a lot with J.B. smooth.
但你会为其他人写剧本，然后给自己安排一句台词，比如演个送货员，试图上台露脸并得分，你知道的，演了10场秀之后你开始得分，他们开始觉得，好吧，那家伙还行。给他几句台词吧。对，明白了。你经常在J·B·斯穆特身上看到那种情况。
He would always read himself into sketches. Oh, yeah. Always see J.B. on there, and you'd be like, oh, yeah. But how cool, you go for your, your audition and it's there with Lorne and Marcy of course and Smigle and you couldn't have known of course that that
他总是把自己的名字写进小品里。哦，对。总是能在上面看到J·B·，然后你会想，哦，对。但是多酷啊，你去参加试镜，有洛恩和玛西，当然还有斯米格尔，你当时当然不可能知道那会演变成这种终生的合作关系。
would become this like lifelong partnership. Yeah. I mean how incredible, how wild right? When you look back at that moment. Yeah, sure man. I mean, smigel was in fact I heard later that smigle was kind of in my court that he was going, that one kid was funny.
是的。我是说，多不可思议，多疯狂，对吧？当你回首那个时刻。是的，当然，伙计。我是说，斯米格尔——事实上我后来听说斯米格尔当时挺支持我的，他说那个年轻人很搞笑。
I think we need that on the show somebody young and they were like, well we already have David and Rob. We don't need any more of that you know and so smigel and jim downy i heard would would stand up for me a little bit and uh lauren liked me he thought i was good he just didn't know what to do with me i was i wasn't easy to digest i was mumbling up there and i was a nervous wreck and i'm hostile like i used to be when somebody heckled me i used to like yell at them and not say anything funny no one is funny or getting pissed off.
我觉得我们需要节目里有这样的人，一个年轻人。而他们说，嗯，我们已经有大卫和罗布了。我们不需要更多那种人了，你知道。所以我听说斯米格尔和吉姆·唐尼会稍微为我仗义执言一下，而且洛恩也喜欢我，他觉得我挺好的，只是不知道该拿我怎么办。我当时有点难以消化，我在上面支支吾吾的，而且我紧张得要死，我还很有敌意——就像以前有人起哄嘘我时，我会冲他们大喊大叫，不说任何好笑的话，没人觉得好笑，反而气急败坏。
Oh, well, I, I turned it into something good, but in the beginning, I used to just be psychotic and get, like, challenge people to something like, curse at him. See, the way he just dropped his face right then. It just got, like, deadly fucking serious. I love, like, there's just, there's no middle with you. Like, he's either super sweet and, like, I can't get out my way. And then just drop the gloves and I'm going to fucking kill you. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
哦，好吧，我把它变成了一件好事，但一开始，我只会精神错乱，像那样去挑衅别人，对他们口出恶言。你看他刚刚脸垮下来的那个样子。立刻变得他妈的极其严肃。我喜欢这种，你跟别人之间没有中间状态。要么超级甜蜜，觉得自己格格不入。然后突然卸下伪装，老子要他妈的弄死你。对，对，对。
I love those swings you, but I don't even know how that happened. I just because I don't want to fight anybody. I'd get, I'd probably get killed, but I was always ready to go. Have you been in a lot of fights as a kid? When I was a kid, when I was a kid, now I would literally just run so fast. Anytime I feel it coming, I start, my heart's pounding through my chest, and I'm like, oh, shit, I got to get out of here. But back then, as a kid, yeah, I'm sure you guys did the same.
我喜欢你这种情绪转换，但我甚至不知道这是怎么发生的。我只是因为我不想跟任何人打架。我大概会被打死，但我总是随时准备开打。你小时候打过很多架吗？我小时候，当我还是个孩子的时候，现在我 literally 会跑得飞快。每当我感觉到有苗头，我的心就开始在胸膛里狂跳，然后我就想，哦，该死，我得离开这儿。但在当年，作为一个孩子，是的，我确信你们也做过同样的事。
It doesn't hurt as much to get hit when you're little. I like the idea that Lauren's going like, hmm, I guess we could use a nervous mumbler. Now, what about, is it true that they fired you and Farley in 95, or is that overstated? No, no, I mean, what happened was kind of the end of it. People, we were repeating ourselves, I'm sure. There was a new guy running NBC. He didn't like the young guys that much.
年纪小的时候挨打没那么疼。我喜欢洛恩那种想法，他心想，嗯，我想我们可以用一个紧张的结巴。话说回来，是不是真的像传闻那样，他们在1995年把你和法利解雇了，还是说这被夸大了？不，不，我的意思是，发生的事情基本上就是那么回事。大家，我们当时在重复自己，这是肯定的。NBC换了个新老板。他不太喜欢年轻人。
He didn't like us. I think he didn't like Norm McDonnell and... He kept saying we got to get rid of them, that nobody likes them. And Lauren was standing up for us, trying to defend us and kept us on a while. And then I got a call from my manager. You know, everyone at Burlstein Gray kind of represented every guy on the show and woman on the show. So I got, hey, maybe it's time to move on to me kind of call. And I was like, I don't know, man.
他不喜欢我们。我觉得他不喜欢诺姆·麦克唐纳和……他一直说我们必须除掉他们，没有人喜欢他们。而洛恩一直在为我们仗义执言，试图保护我们，让我们多留了一段时间。然后我接到了经纪人的电话。你知道，伯尔斯坦·格雷公司的每个人基本上都代理了节目里的每一个男演员和女演员。所以我接到了那种“嘿，也许是时候向前看了”的电话。我说，我不知道，伙计。
I think maybe I'll do another year or something. They were like, yeah, but maybe you should move on. like, nah, I want to stay. I think I'll stay. And they kept going, I think it's time to move on. I was like, do I have to move on? They were like, it's good if you move on. I was like, okay, okay, now I got you.
我想我可能会再干一年什么的。他们就说，对，但也许你应该向前看。我说，不，我想留下来。我想我还是留下来吧。他们一直说，我觉得是时候向前看了。我说，我非得向前看不可吗？他们说，如果你能向前看就最好了。我说，好吧，好吧，我懂了。
All right, I'm moving on there. So it was kind of like a fake quit, fake, trying to get up, beat them to firing me. That was like me at every high school I went to. I swear to God. Really? You got kicked out? I'm like, no, I didn't get kicked out. They just asked me not to return.
好吧，我要向前看了。所以那有点像是一次假装辞职，假装抢在他们解雇我之前主动离开。那就像我在我上过的每一所高中时的表现一样。我发誓。真的吗？你被开除了？我不是被开除的。他们只是要求我不要再回去了。
What did you do to get in trouble growing up? I did all the stupid stuff. I was, you know, smoking cigarettes. I grew up in Canada, so there were a lot of woods to escape, too. Yeah, yeah. So I was always out there, like, you know, drinking airplane bottles and smoking butts and all this stuff. I was just, but also I was a wise ass. I was like, I said to my dad actually once, I was such a wise ass.
你小时候惹麻烦都干过什么？我都干过那些蠢事。我当时，你知道，抽烟。我在加拿大长大，所以有很多树林可以逃进去。对，对。所以我总是待在那里，你知道，喝着小瓶装的飞机酒，抽着烟头，所有这些。我只是，但同时我还是个滑头。我甚至有一次对我爸说，我太滑头了。
And, of course, the worst, the infractioner, the bigger the joke that you can make, especially at the teacher's expense, the bigger the laugh you'd get from the audience, or as I'd call my classmates. And so I would fuck around and they'd get really mad. And years later, I remember my dad was out here and I just built this house and it was like everything. And my dad was like, wow, this house is beautiful. And I said, yeah, who knew that fucking around could pay off, huh?
当然，惹出的麻烦越大，你能开的玩笑就越大，特别是以牺牲老师为代价，你能从观众——或者我称之为同学的人——那里得到的笑声就越大。所以我到处胡闹，他们就会非常生气。多年后，我记得我爸来到这里，我刚盖好了这座房子，里面什么都有。我爸说，哇，这房子真漂亮。我说，对，谁知道胡闹也能有回报呢，对吧？
And he finally had to admit like, man, you're kind of right because I was a pain in the ass. You know what I mean? Like my poor dad. Ah, sure, sure, man. You figure out how to channel it. Yeah. All right.
他最后不得不承认，天哪，你某种程度上是对的，因为我以前确实是个让人头疼的混蛋。你知道我的意思吗？我可怜的爸爸。啊，当然，当然，伙计。你找到了引导这种能量的方法。对。好吧。
So then were things sort of set up in a way where transitioning out of that show and into other possible sources of employment were kind of set up? Like, were you feeling confident? Yeah. Did you go right into? Was it Happy Gilmore? Was first out of there? I think I did Billy Madison when I was on the show.
那么，当时的情况是否安排得很好，让你能够顺利从那个节目过渡到其他潜在的工作来源？你当时感觉自信吗？是的。你直接就去拍了吗？是《快乐的吉尔摩》吗？那是从那出来的第一部作品吗？我想我在节目里时拍了《白赖恩·麦迪逊》。
By the way, when I got fired, I was confident until I got fired. And then I was like, oh, no. Yeah, that's the way that works. Right? I kept while I was there going, these guys, they'll get it. what I got, man, they don't understand. And then right when they were like, yeah, go do it on your own then, I was like, holy shit. First of all, you humiliated that people don't want you.
顺便说一句，当我被解雇时，我很自信，直到我被解雇的那一刻。然后我想，哦，不。对，事情就是那样运作的。对吧？我在那里时一直觉得，这些家伙，他们会明白的。明白我的实力，伙计，他们不懂。然后就在他们说，好吧，那你就自己去干吧的时候，我心想，卧槽。首先，你因为别人不想要你了而感到羞辱。
And you got to tell people like, yeah, I'm not on the show when they're looking you in the eyes going, you got fired? And you're like, no, you know, you're making up shit. But it's like doing what we do, you're effectively getting fired at the end of every single job. You have to go find another job. And if you're having a really good year as an actor, you're, you're, you're, get fired like six or seven times you know like you've got six or seven and you have like there's
而且你得告诉别人，对，我不在那个节目里了，当他们看着你的眼睛问你，你被开除了吗？你就会说，没有，你知道，你在胡编乱造。但这就跟我们做的事一样，你实际上在每一份工作的尾声都会被解雇。你必须去找另一份工作。如果你作为演员正经历一个非常好的年份，你就会，你就会，被解雇六七次，你知道，就像你有六七次……而且没有保障，没有一张文凭能让你……这是真的，伙计，这是一场接一场的工作面试，而且……我记得曾经买过那种我本该去租的房子，当事情有点干涸，而我原本信心满满，直到他们不再需要我，然后就像，好吧，现在你必须建立起一整套自我和应对机制，来让自己重新建立自信，这种自信不能依赖于是否有工作，这真的很难做到。天哪，是的，坐在冷板凳上，心神不宁。我告诉你，说真的，我小时候超级喜欢你。我觉得你太不可思议了。
no guarantee there's no diploma that you can kind of it's true man it's job interview after job interview and it's it's i remember buying the attitude that i realized i should have been renting when you know things kind of dried up and i was really confident until they just didn't want me anymore and it's like well now you got to build up a whole ego and and and and and and coping mechanism to get yourself confident that's not reliant on employment that's really hard to do it all God, yeah, sit in the bench and being shook up. I'll tell you, no kidding, I loved you when I was a kid. I thought you were incredible.
我发誓，我觉得你酷毙了。你们也是吗？对，我觉得你，超级粉丝。我想长得像你。我想他妈的变得像你那样冷酷、沉着、搞笑。我一直觉得你太棒了。我没对你撒谎。我也很喜欢你姐姐。
I swear to God, I thought you were cool as shit. You guys, too? Yeah, I thought you were, huge fan. I wanted to look like you. I wanted to fucking be, like, cool and calm and funny like that. And I always thought you were awesome. I'm not lying to you. I loved your sister, too.
谢谢。你还记得杰森的节目吗？他演过那个节目，《轮到你了》。你以前看过吗？那是《银匙》的衍生剧。我想是的，对，对，对，我想是的。但我认为我更了解之后的《霍根一家》或者瓦莱丽，对，对。当杰森在这里的好莱坞星光大道上获得他的星形奖章时，
Thank you. Do you remember Jason's show? He had that show, It's Your Move. Did you ever see that? It was like a spinoff of Silver Spoon. I think so, yeah, yeah, yeah, I think so. But I think I knew more on the Hogan family was after that, or Valerie, yeah, yeah. When Jason got his star on the walk of fame out here in Hollywood,
因为他是个大好莱坞红人。所以当他在好莱坞时，我们很担心，因为他是个自由派精英。所以无论如何，我上台了，他们让我，他让我说几句话，我说，你知道，当我长大时，我记得我看过《成长的烦恼》，看到杰森·贝特曼，心想，天哪，不知道她有没有兄弟。太棒了，老兄。但我很喜欢他。
because he's a big Hollywood guy. So when he was in Hollywood, we're worried because he's a liberal elite. And so anyway, so I get up and they asked me, he asked me to say a couple words, and I said, you know, when I was growing up, I remember watching family ties and seeing Justin Bateman and thinking, man, I wonder if she's got a brother. That's so good, my man. But I loved him.
我们有同感。这种事经常发生。我们过去总是看着杰森心想，哦，天哪，那家伙，因为他是个小机灵鬼，他很自信。他有一头好头发。哦，我当时太自信了。我觉得自己牛逼轰轰的。然后电话就不响了。
We felt the same way. This comes up all the time. We used to always look at Jason and be like, oh, man, that guy's, because he was a smart ass, he was confident. He had great hair. Oh, I was so confident. I thought I was such hot shit. And then the phone stopped ringing.
我当时不知所措。我的二十岁是一段全面的整顿期。我不得不从零开始重新建立起来。我和杰森几十年前在马蒙城堡酒店吃过午餐，那是一家容纳自由派精英的酒店。没错。杰森当时对我说——我不知道你还记得吗，杰森。你对我说，我们当时在谈论职业生涯以及其他事情，有起有落。你说，这一切都不是你能决定的。
I did not know what to do. My 20s was a whole regroup. I just had to build it back up from zero. Jason and I had lunch like decades ago at the Chateau Marmont, which houses the liberal elite. That's right. And Jason said to me, I don't know if you remember this, Jason. You said to me, we were just talking about careers and whatever, the ups and downs. And you said, none of it is up to you.
这一切都不是你能决定的。对，对。试图去控制那些你无法控制的事情。这不是一个精英统治的体系。你知道的，就像在体育界，如果你是一个3成打击率的球员，你就保住了饭碗。这倒也是。但在表演或任何形式的艺术中，它是如此主观。你不能，你不能依赖于“我是唱歌最好的”或者“我是画画最好的”，这根本不重要。
None of this is up to you. Yeah, yeah. To try and control things that are out of your control. It's not a meritocracy. You know, like in sports, like if you're a 300 hitter, you're guaranteed employment. That's true. In acting or any form of part in the term art, it's so subjective. You can't, you can't rely on, well, I'm the best at singing or the best at painting or it doesn't matter.
在谁的眼里是最好的呢，你知道吗？然后，亚当，所以顺着这个思路，我觉得你所做的事情中有一点真的很棒，你取得了难以置信的成功。但是，（你知道的），我一直在努力，特别是在过去几年里，我不想让我的工作来定义我作为一个人的身份，也不想让它定义我有快乐。关于家庭。我知道你是个非常顾家的男人。当然。你有很多非常亲密的朋友。对。甚至在你的工作中，你做你想做的事，你做那些你知道需要花时间的事，然后你知道它会，你知道的，它会占用学校的时间和所有那些乱七八糟的事。感觉你把一切都调整得能够适应你的生活，并确保你快乐以及你的幸福。你真的不是一个好莱坞那种类型的人。我可以这么说。你没有被它定义，对吧？我算是，你知道，我很幸运能拥有这样的职业生涯，得到了正确的东西并能够去做，并不是每个人都有这种奢侈。我确信如果他们能的话，会有更多人做我正在做的事，你知道的，只要对公司负责人说，嘿，让我在十月做这件事，因为，你知道的，我有很多运气站在我这边。但你赢得了这个地位。
The best in whose eye, you know? And then so, Adam, so kind of taking that, like one of the things that I think is really awesome about what you've done, you've had incredible success. But is, you know, I've tried to, especially in the last couple of years, I don't want my work to define who I am as a person or how happy I am. about family. I know you're a really big family guy. Sure. You've got a lot of really close friends. Yeah. And even in your work, you do stuff that you want to do and you do stuff because you know it's going to take time and then you know that it's, you know, it cuts into school and all that kind of stuff. And it feels like you gear everything towards making it fit your
你确实赢得了它。我过了一段时间才得到这个，过了一段时间。对，让我非常快地问你关于这的一件事。然后回到威尔刚才说的话，因为当你年轻的时候，你第一次涉足电影，那种成功有多少是——你知道的，经纪业务驱动的，你只是顺其自然；又有多少是你自己发起的，是带着雄心壮志直接从你身上迸发出来的？我有一种奇怪的雄心壮志。我只是，我一开始总是得到，嘿，好吧，好吧，好吧。也许下次他们会雇别人，当我参加试镜之类的时候。
life and making sure that you're happy and your happiness. You're truly not a Hollywood guy. I can say that. And you don't define yourself by it, right? I kind of, you know, I lucked into having the career of getting the right stuff and get to do it, and not everybody has that luxury. I'm sure more people would do what I'm doing if they could just, you know, just say to the head of a company, hey, let me do it in October because it's, you know, I got a lot of luck on my side. But you earned that position.
我记得年轻时去为几部电影试镜，当我大约21、22岁时，他们总是选别人，然后我想，天哪，这些家伙真是不懂，伙计。我曾是个彻头彻尾的混蛋，你知道的，无论他们选了谁，我都会想，哦，对，好吧，伙计，就像我犯了个大错，真是个大错。然后我和蒂姆·赫利在《周六夜现场》共事时一起写了《白赖恩·麦迪逊》，我把它交给了洛恩，而洛恩当时已经和克里斯在拍《汤米小子》了。所以……一部搞笑的电影？
You really have. I got that after a while, after a while. Yeah, let me really quick ask you something about that. And then back to what Will was saying, because when you were, younger and you broke into film for the first time and how much of that success was like, you know, agent business driven and you were just along for the ride and how much of it was self-generated and kind of ambitiously coming directly from you. I was ambitious in a weird way. I just, I always kind of got in the beginning, hey, yeah, yeah, yeah. Maybe next time they
你真的有。过了一会儿我明白了，过了一会儿。是的，让我很快问你一个关于这个的问题。然后回到威尔刚才说的话，因为当你们还年轻，第一次涉足电影界时，有多少成功是靠经纪业务推动的，你只是顺其自然，又有多少是自我创造的、真正来自你自己的雄心壮志？我曾以一种奇怪的方式雄心勃勃。我只是，一开始我总是会得到这样的回应，嘿，对，对，对。也许下次吧，他们
would hire somebody else when I would do auditions and stuff. I remember auditioning for a few movies as a kid when i was like 21 22 and they'd always pick somebody else and i was like god damn these guys don't get it man and uh i was such an asshole you know and uh whoever they picked i would be like oh yeah okay man like i was hot mistake yeah what a mistake and then i i wrote billy madison with tim hurley and when we were on saturday night live and i gave it to to lord and Lauren was already doing Tommy Boy with Chris. And so... A funny movie?
以前我去试镜的时候总会录用别人。我记得小时候大概21、22岁时去试镜过几部电影，他们总是选别人，我当时就想，天啊，这些人真是不识货，我以前真是个混蛋，你知道的，无论他们选了谁，我都会说，哦，好吧，就像我犯了个大错，真是个大错。后来我和蒂姆·赫利在《周六夜现场》工作时一起写了《比利·麦迪逊》，我把它交给了洛恩，而洛恩当时已经在和克里斯一起制作《汤米小子》了。所以……一部搞笑的电影？
Oh, yeah, that's awesome. And he was... It was the first time me and Chris had an either-or kind of thing. And Lauren said, we're doing Tommy Boy. We can't do Billy Madison. Actually, Tommy Boy used to be called Billy the Third. It was two Billy movies. Yeah, they were like two...
哦，对，太棒了。而且他……那是我和克里斯第一次面临二选一的情况。劳伦说，我们要拍《Tommy Boy》。我们不能拍《Billy Madison》。其实，《Tommy Boy》以前叫《比利第三》。那是两部关于比利电影。对，它们就像两部……
The two Billy movies. And we would look at each other like, who's the getting to pick? And they picked, you know, Tommy. boy. And I was going, oh, man, oh, man, I guess that's done. We'll write another one, Hurley He. And then, like, I was in this movie called Airheads. And the producer of that one called me, like, five months later. He's like, I read this script, you and Hurley Hero called Billy Madison. Do you want to do that? And I said, yeah, yeah, yeah. Why? What do you mean? He was like, I could get that Dunfear for like six million dollar budget. I was like, I get six million dollars. He goes, no, not, not you.
两部关于比利的电影。我们看着对方，心想，谁能来挑？结果他们挑了，你知道的，Tommy Boy。而我当时就在想，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，看来这事儿泡汤了。我们再写一个吧，Hurley He。然后，就像，我当时在拍一部叫《头脑特工队》（Airheads）的电影。那部电影的制片人在大约五个月后打电话给我。他说，我看了这个剧本，你和Hurley He写的叫《Billy Madison》。你想演吗？我说，想想想。为什么？你什么意思？他说，我可以用大约六百万美元的预算拿下邓费尔。我当时想，我能拿到六百万美元吗？他说，不，不，不是你。
I don't know what any of that shit meant. But he got it fucking, he did Problem Child at Universal, which was a low budget movie and made a lot of money. So they said, get some more of those kind of things. So somehow Bob Simon's got this movie. I asked Lauren, I said,
我不知道那些破事儿是什么意思。但他他妈的成功了，他在环球影业拍了《小鬼当格》（Problem Child），那是一部低成本电影，赚了很多钱。所以他们说，再搞点这种类型的东西。所以不知怎么的，鲍勃·西蒙斯弄到了这部电影。我问劳伦，我说，
that movie you said, you didn't want to do. Is it okay if I do it with this other guy? He's like, do anything you want. So I did Billy Madison. And then that kind of got me going, I mean, I remember when I first said that, everything that they talked to me about doing
那部你说你不想拍的电影。如果我和另一个人一起拍，可以吗？他说，你想做什么都行。于是我拍了《Billy Madison》。然后这让我开始运转了，我的意思是，我记得当我第一次说那个的时候，他们找我谈的所有事情
after that was doing my goofy voice and being very, you know, the same Billy Madison again. And then I had that happy Gilmore thing that me and Hurley, he wrote. And they were trying to talk me out of that. They were saying, there was a movie called Ed with the monkey, you know.
在那之后，都是让我用滑稽的嗓音，然后非常，你知道的，再次扮演那个一模一样的Billy Madison。然后我有了我和Hurley He写的那个《欢乐皮尔斯》（Happy Gilmore）的东西。他们当时正试图劝我放弃那个。他们说，有一部叫《艾德》（Ed）的电影，里面有只猴子，你知道的。
No, no, no, that's Ed TV. It's one with Matt, Matt LeBlanc. And they want to be With the monkey And they were like, do that That's more like Billy Madison I said, I think Let me do
不，不，不，那是《艾德电视台》（Ed TV）。是马特，马特·勒布朗演的那部。他们想要那部有猴子的电影。他们说，去演那个吧，那更像《Billy Madison》。我说，我想，让我先拍
I'll do that one after I do the golf one Is that okay? They were like, no And so I had to make a stand And say, no, no, no We gotta do this Happy Gilmore movie And by the way, two of the funniest movies ever No kidding
等我拍完那个高尔夫电影我再拍那个行吗？他们说，不行。所以我必须表明立场，说，不，不，不，我们得拍这部《欢乐皮尔斯》电影。顺便说一句，这是有史以来最搞笑的两部电影之一。不开玩笑。
A hugely successful Fuck Thanks I mean, they're good I'm psyched that That's in my They go down in history as with all the other great comedy movies.
巨大成功。他妈的，谢谢。我的意思是，它们很棒。我很兴奋，那是我的……它们将作为所有其他伟大的喜剧电影一起载入史册。
I mean, it's kind of cool. But then the success was so, one after the other, after the other, was there a strategic consideration when Punch Drunk Love came about? Or was that more of a reaction, did Paul Thomas Anderson come to you and only in hindsight,
我的意思是，这挺酷的。但随后成功接踵而至，一部接一部，当《狂野之爱》（Punch-Drunk Love）出现时，有没有什么战略上的考虑？或者这更多是一种反应，是保罗·托马斯·安德森（Paul Thomas Anderson）主动来找你的，还是只有在事后，
do you see it as a great strategic sort of balancing thing, offsetting the goofiness? Or did you think ahead and kind of seek out something that might counterbalance all that? That was all luck. I mean, in my head, Will, you did Strasbourg, right? So I thought I was good at acting.
你才把它看作是一种伟大的战略平衡，用来对冲那些滑稽搞笑？还是你提前考虑过，并主动寻找能够平衡所有这些的东西？那纯粹是运气。我的意思是，在我心里，威尔，你上过斯特拉斯堡（Strasbourg）表演学校，对吧？所以我以为我很擅长演戏。
I was like, wow, I'm going to surprise somebody someday and really act. But it wasn't on my mind. I kind of liked Eddie Murphy, and I wanted that kind of career, and I just wanted to be a comedian. And then I was doing, I think, Little Nicky or something like that. Or, yeah, something like that. and Paul was friends with Tom Cruise. They did Magnolia together.
我当时想，哇，总有一天我要给某人一个惊喜，真正地去演戏。但这并不在我的脑海里。我有点喜欢埃迪·墨菲，我想要那种类型的职业生涯，我只是想成为一名喜剧演员。然后我当时在拍，我想，可能是《魔鬼接班人》（Little Nicky）或者类似的电影。或者，对，类似的东西。而且保罗和汤姆·克鲁斯是朋友。他们一起合作了《木兰花》（Magnolia）。
And I met Tom Cruise when Nicole Kim and hosted S&L. You know how you get to meet everybody because of SNL? So I met Cruz and I, my God, Cruz had a Yankee hat on, like, dipped down low. And he looked up and he goes, hey, man, I was like, in love with him. Like, oh, my God, I'm in love with Tom Cruise. That makes true of us. Of course.
我和妮可·基德曼主持周六夜现场（SNL）时我遇到了汤姆·克鲁斯。你知道你怎么通过SNL认识每个人的吗？所以我遇到了克鲁斯，我，我的天哪，克鲁斯戴着一顶洋基队的帽子，压得低低的。他抬起头说，嘿，伙计，我当时就像，爱上了他。就像，哦，天哪，我爱上了汤姆·克鲁斯。这证明了我们俩的心思。当然。
Anyways, Tom called me up. I'm on my set. He goes, hey, my friend, I'm doing a movie with my friend Paul. He's a great director, and he's interested in doing a movie with you. Can I put him on the phone? Wow. And I said, yeah, yeah, sure, man. And he gets on, and Paul was very nice, and he was going,
不管怎样，汤姆给我打电话。我在片场。他说，嘿，我的朋友，我和我的朋友保罗在拍一部电影。他是个伟大的导演，他有兴趣和你合作一部电影。我能让他接电话吗？哇。我说，好，好，当然，伙计。然后他接了电话，保罗非常友好，他说，
hey, I loved Billy Madison. And I go, okay, man, thanks. I didn't know who he was. And he's like, and I just love your movies and your albums. And I was like, okay, good. Cool, man. Okay, creep. I didn't know what he was talking about.
嘿，我很喜欢《Billy Madison》。我说，好吧，伙计，谢谢。我当时不知道他是谁。他说，我就是喜欢你的电影和你的专辑。我说，好吧，好的。酷，伙计。好吧，怪胎。我不知道他在说什么。
He's like, he goes, is it okay if I write you a movie? I said, you can do whatever you want, man. That's great. Just stay away from my house. But he was sweet. I can tell you it was funny, but. That's like Picasso saying, is it okay if I paint you a painting? I know, right?
他说，他接着说，我给你写部电影可以吗？我说，你想做什么都行，伙计。太棒了。只要别离我房子远点就行。但他很甜美。我可以告诉你这很搞笑，但是。这就好像毕加索说，我给你画幅画可以吗？我懂，对吧？
I know. It was the luckiest thing. And then, and honest to God, fellas, I was, it was like 11 o'clock in the morning. and I had nothing to do and Magnolia just came out and I said I think that's that kid's movie Paul I'm going to go see that and I went alone
我懂。这是最幸运的事。然后，说实话，伙计们，当时大约是早上11点。我无所事事，《木兰花》刚上映，我说我想去看那个小孩的电影，保罗，我要去看看。我一个人去的。
and I was in the front row it was sold out with all real film kind of people and I was looking up at it and I was going I was fucking terrified I was like oh this guy's fucking better than me man I don't want to fucking be in this I'm going to ruin his movie
我坐在第一排，座无虚席，全都是真正的电影圈的人。我抬头看着银幕，我当时在想，我他妈吓坏了。我当时想，哦，这家伙他妈的比我强，伙计，我他妈不想参演这个，我会毁了他的电影。
whatever to fly you know I was like holy shit and I called him up and on the way home And I was like, holy shit, I just saw your movie. He's like, yeah, yeah. I was like, fuck, and the frogs and the, holy shit. I was so excited about everybody.
管他怎么飞呢，你知道的，我当时想，天哪。我在回家的路上给他打电话。我说，天哪，我刚看了你的电影。他说，对，对。我说，他妈的，还有那些青蛙，还有那些，天哪。我为每个人感到那么兴奋。
And I was like, oh, fuck, man. And so you're right in that movie, man? He goes, yeah, yeah, I'm almost done. I'm going to get it over to you. I was like, well, when the fuck is that coming? You know, I started to get very excited. Wow. And then he did it so cool, man.
我当时想，哦，操，伙计。那你也演了那部电影吗，伙计？他说，对，对，我快写完了。我这就拿给你。我当时想，那他妈什么时候出来？你知道的，我开始变得非常兴奋。哇。然后他做得太酷了，伙计。
I lived in this, this, I rented a house on the top of Bel Air Road with my buddies. And he came up. And he knocked on the door and he's like, I got the script. And I said, here's my present to you. And I go, okay. He goes, go ahead and read it and tell me what you think. And I go, you're going to stay here? He goes, no, I'm going to go for a drive or something like that.
我住在贝莱尔路（Bel Air Road）顶端的一个房子里，是我和哥们儿一起租的。他上来了。他敲门说，我有剧本了。我说，这是我送给你的礼物。我说，好吧。他说，快读读看，告诉我你的想法。我说，你要呆在这儿吗？他说，不，我要去兜风或者干点别的。
And I just sat in the other room and I read it. And I was like, oh, my God, man, I don't know if I can fucking do this. No way. And so he comes back after his drive and you got a bunch of notes, right? You're like, great. A couple things, Paul. It's all marked up. It's on move this.
然后我就坐在另一个房间里读了起来。我当时想，哦，天哪，伙计，我不知道我他妈能不能演这个。绝对不行。然后他兜风回来问我你有一堆意见对吧？你就像，太棒了。有几点意见，保罗。上面都标出来了。这个得移到……
That's true. No, I was fucking scared. Like, like, you know, when you get something and you just go, oh, she's, man. I always said I can do this ship and this is too much, man. And he talked me through and got me comfortable. He's incredible, though. I mean, his taste is just unreal. I love that he's a huge comedy nerd, too, apparently.
真的吗？不，我他妈吓坏了。就像，你知道的，当你拿到什么东西时，你就会说，哦，天哪，伙计。我总是说我能搞定这破事儿，但这太过了，伙计。他开导我，让我放松下来。不过他真的很不可思议。我是说，他的品味简直无法无天。我喜欢他显然也是一个超级喜剧迷。
Oh, man, yeah. And that he can see the amount of acting. it takes for you to pull off believably what you do is right in line with his with his taste and his abilities and i just i'm such a big fan of his and then the safty brothers um you know i mean uncut gems is just absolutely stunning i don't mean they love you too but they had fun at talking betty and you talking at annesons was a great night i just i'm crazy about those guys as well and i love the two of my favorite filmmakers well that would be three um i put you as a lead in their films. And I hope that you take
哦，伙计，是的。而且他能看出你为了完美演绎你的角色所需要的演技水平，这完全符合他的品味和能力。我真的是他的超级粉丝。然后萨夫迪兄弟（Safdie brothers），嗯，你知道的，我是说《原钻》（Uncut Gems）简直太震撼了。我不是说他们也爱你，但他们在聊贝蒂（Betty）时玩得很开心，你在安尼斯顿（Annesons）聊天的那晚也是个美好的夜晚。我也超级迷恋那群家伙，我爱他们俩，我最喜欢的电影制作人，好吧，那就是三个……我让你们俩在他们的电影里演主角。我希望你对此感到
as much pride in that as you deserve. That was an incredible performance, man. It really was. It was, it was, it was so nuanced and deep in this guy. Like, it was... You guys, you know, honestly, you could do it, you guys could do it too. I know you're all great, all three, you guys are great actors
和应得的一样骄傲。那真是不可思议的表演，伙计。真的是。它是，它是，它是那么细腻，对这个角色的挖掘那么深。就像，它是……你们，你知道的，老实说，你们也能做到，你们俩也能做到。我知道你们都很棒，你们三个，你们都是伟大的演员
and funny as shit. And... Who's better? Yeah. Is there one that's better? You're number one. Sure. Yeah, okay. Definitely. We're fighting for the silver over here. Yeah, you don't need. You're both solid but for Sean's number one so the I would imagine that you um you you you love the the creative process of doing a drama um and also the process of doing a comedy I'm not
而且搞笑得要命。还有……谁更好？对。有没有哪个更好一点的？你是第一。当然。对，好吧。绝对的。我们在为银牌而战呢。对，你不需要。你们俩都很稳，但肖恩是第一，所以……我猜你，嗯，你，你，你喜欢拍正剧的创作过程……还有拍喜剧的过程。我不是
going to ask you which is your favorite but what would be your ideal ratio between comedy and drama and like kind of like fun films with your friends versus kind of working for a director I'm starting to get a lot of uh serious kind of offers and and and I love I love reading that stuff, and I, but it is more of a decision in my brain. I'm like, shit, once I say yes to that, then it's fucking, it's a whole other thing in your trailer and you're fucking rocked and you got to think into shit that makes you uncomfortable and it's slightly humiliating out there in front of people doing some of the shit they want you to do. And so it's a decision, but I like it.
要问你哪个是你的最爱，但你觉得喜剧和正剧之间的理想比例是多少？比如和朋友拍好玩的电影，与为某个导演工作相比。我开始接到很多严肃类型的邀约，而且我喜欢，我喜欢读那些东西。但这更多是我脑子里的一个决定。我想，操，一旦我答应了那个，那他妈的，你在化妆车里就是完全另一码事了，你他妈压力山大，你得去琢磨那些让你感到不舒服的事情，而且在人们面前做他们想让你做的一些破事儿，多多少少有点屈辱。所以这是一个决定，但我喜欢它。
I want to do that stuff, but I also love doing the comedy shit. and the fact that, you know, I just did probably the goofiest movie I've done in a long time that, you know, shit I would have done when I was 23. And, but I still, I'm still happy doing it. Hubey, Hubey Halloween. Yeah, yeah, yeah. What is it? What is, I don't know anything about it. It's on Netflix, right?
我想做那种事，但我也喜欢搞笑。而且事实上，你知道的，我刚刚拍了我很长一段时间以来拍过的最滑稽的电影，你知道的，这都是我23岁时会做的事。而且，但我仍然，我拍得还是很开心。《休比的万圣节》（Hubey Hubey Halloween）。对，对，对。那是什么？是什么？我对它一无所知。在Netflix上对吧？
It's coming out on Netflix, uh, and it's a Halloween movie and it's all comedians and all, it's like a... And our kids will love it, yeah? And my end of kids, I do that because I get excited for kids to laugh. and stuff like that and shit I've been doing my whole career and I still love that stuff. But being able to do both, I mean, good God,
它要在Netflix上上映了，嗯，这是一部万圣节电影，里面全都是喜剧演员，全都是，就像一个……我们的孩子会喜欢的，对吧？说到孩子们，我拍这个是因为看到孩子们笑我会感到兴奋。之类的事情，还有我整个职业生涯一直在做的事情，我依然热爱这些。但能够两者兼顾，我的意思是，天哪，
you can make, you know, an eight-year-old laugh and you can make, you know, a 70-year-old cry. I mean, it's like, come on. Like, not a lot of people can do that at all. Thank you. I'm lucky, yeah, yeah.
你能让一个八岁的孩子笑，你也能让一个七十岁的老人哭。我的意思是，这简直是，拜托。没有几个人能做到这一点。谢谢。我很幸运，对，对。
Adam, you said, I read somewhere a long time ago, you said, I'll do this for as long as they let me. Yeah. And they, I love that. And they keep letting you because you're incredible and talented and likable and winning? And is there a time when you actually tell them that you're done or are you still having the time of your life?
亚当，你曾经说过，我很久以前在什么地方读到过你说的话，你说，只要他们让我拍，我就会一直拍下去。对。我喜欢这个。而且他们一直在让你拍，因为你不可思议、很有才华、讨人喜欢而且总能赢？有没有那么一个时刻，你真的告诉他们你拍够了，还是说你依然在享受你生命中最美好的时光？
Like, what else? Because you work more than anybody. Like, you never stop working. I don't know when I'm going to stop. I look at like, you know, I know Dustin and I know Nicholson and Pacino and those guys and those guys, they're addicted to work too. I mean, I had lunch with Petchino.
比如，还有什么？因为你比任何人都工作得多。你从来没有停止过工作。我不知道我什么时候会停下来。我看着，你知道的，我认识达斯汀，我认识尼克尔森和阿尔·帕西诺以及那些家伙，那些家伙，他们也对工作上瘾。我的意思是，我和帕西诺一起吃过午饭。
and he still gets excited about shit. And he's just, I read this amazing script and he still wants to kick ass. And I kind of think I could stop. And then when I'm stuck like this pandemic, man, would not work. And holy shit was I lose in my mind. And fucking every day becomes the same jumpy shit. And my fucking family certainly wanted me to work. They were like, Jesus Christ, he's fucking insane.
他对事情仍然充满热情。而且他只是，我读了这个惊人的剧本，他仍然想大干一场。我一度以为我可以停下来。然后当遇到像这次大流行病这样被困住的时候，伙计，就没法工作了。天哪，我当时简直要疯了。他妈的每一天都变成了一样令人焦虑的破事儿。我他妈的家人当然希望我工作。他们就像，耶稣基督，他他妈疯了。
Get him out of here. I heard you were out on the golf course a little. Yeah, we heard from a friend that... Oh, I hit into you, buddy. Yeah. Who's your buddy that I almost hit, by the way? Tom Warner. Tell Tommy, I'm sorry.
把他弄走吧。我听说你经常去高尔夫球场。对，我们从一个朋友那里听说……哦，我打球砸到你了吧，伙计。对。顺便问一下，你那个差点被我砸到的朋友是谁？汤姆·沃纳（Tom Warner）。代我向汤姆道歉。
Okay. Are you a big golfer? Because I'm finding that that is keeping me off the streets a little bit during this pandemic. You've been playing a lot? Yeah. Well, you know, I met you a long time ago, like 20 years ago, and you were friends with Brill. Yeah. I think back then, and I was at a party, and I saw some thing that,
好的。你是个狂热的高尔夫球手吗？因为我发现这在大流行期间让我稍微远离了街头。你最近经常打吗？对。嗯，你知道的，我很早就认识你了，大约20年前，你和布里尔（Brill）是朋友。对。我想在那时，我在一个派对上，我看到了一些东西，
They interviewed you on, like, a show, and you had a, you golfed on it. And I saw you at the thing. I said, dude, I just saw you did. You got a great swing. And you kind of like, okay, okay, and that was it. But I remember, go, oh, that fucking guy knows how to golf. He's got a great swing. He does have a great swing.
他们在某个节目里采访你，你在上面打高尔夫球。我在那个活动上看到了你。我说，老兄，我刚看你打球了。你的挥杆真棒。你当时有点像，好吧，好吧，就这样。但我记得，心想，哦，那个混蛋懂得怎么打高尔夫。他的挥杆真棒。他的挥杆确实很棒。
I didn't have a career at that point. He's got a great swing. We've both taken it up in the last couple of weeks. We've been a little irritating to our significant others. Yeah, it's a long day, golf day, right? Are you addicted to it, or is it just something? you just kind of slap around. No, I tell you, your buddy, what happened was I'm a member of Riviera
我当时还没有事业。他的挥杆真棒。我们俩最近几周都开始打了。对我们的另一半来说，我们有点烦人。对，高尔夫日是很长的一天，对吧？你对它上瘾了，还是只是把它当成……随便挥挥杆。不，我跟你说，你的哥们儿，事情是这样的，我是里维埃拉（Riviera）高尔夫俱乐部的会员。
and I fucking live right down the street. So I haven't golfed. Since I've had kids, I don't golf that much, just like you're saying, Will. Because of the whole five hours away and the stare you get when you get home of like, are you fucking kidding me? But while they're in school, we've got to pass while they're in school, right? That's right. That's supposed to be it.
而我他妈的就住在街对面。所以我一直没怎么打。自从有了孩子以后，我就不怎么打高尔夫了，就像你说的，威尔。因为要花整整五个小时，而且当你回到家时，迎接你的是那种眼神，仿佛在说：你他妈在逗我吗？但当他们在上学时，我们在他们上学期间可以获得一张“通行证”，对吧？没错。本来应该是这样的。
But I still get nervous leaving the house and coming back to it. a fucking uh whole other mood so uh i i i know what you guys are talking about because when i make banana bread i'm like do i do i pull it out at the right like when is the do i leave it in five another five minutes do i not it's crazy just like it well listen i know you must feel guilty about paying all those dues over there at riviera and not using the course so will and i want to help you out yeah i'm going to help you just kind of getting a little bit more active out there so you just let us know you guys are playing real well like in the 80s or 70s no well he is I'm playing like shit, but Jason's game is getting together.
但我离开家又回来时还是会感到紧张。他妈的会遇到另一种情绪，所以我，我知道你们在说什么，因为当我烤香蕉面包时，我在想，我是不是，我是不是在正确的时机把它拿出来——什么时候才是……我是不是该再烤五分钟？我是不是不该？这太疯狂了，就像……好吧，听着，我知道你一定为在里维埃拉交了那么多会费却不用球场而感到内疚，所以我和威尔想帮帮你。对，我要帮你多在球场上活动活动，所以你只要告诉我们。你们打得挺好吧，比如在80多杆或者70多杆？不，好吧，他打得好，我打得像坨狗屎，但杰森的状态正在恢复。
But what we've been doing is we've been calling guys that we know who we know belong places because we don't. And we go, that's where you come in. Hey, you're playing these days? And then they go, yeah. And we go, well, Jason, we're available on Wednesday. Willing to keep you company. Wow, man.
但我们一直在做的是，我们会打电话给我们认识的、我们知道有会籍的人，因为我们没有。然后我们说，这就是你派上用场的时候了。嘿，这几天打球吗？然后他们说，打啊。然后我们说，好吧，杰森，我们星期三有空。愿意陪你解闷。哇，伙计。
Adam, I'm always special. I always ask funny parents this. Like, Will and Jason are two of the funniest people I know. They always make me laugh so hard. And we've always talked about do their kids find them, Do your kids find, and you're obviously fucking hilarious. Your kids find you funny or not at all? Or, like, do they get your sense of comedy?
亚当，我一直很特别。我总是问有趣的父母这个问题。比如，威尔和杰森是我认识的最搞笑的两个人。他们总是能让我捧腹大笑。我们一直在讨论，他们的孩子觉得他们好笑吗？你的孩子觉得你好笑吗，还是根本觉得不好笑？或者，比如，他们懂你的幽默感吗？
Do they watch your funny movies, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, I'm pretty good at home. I'm happy when I make them laugh because when I'm asking him to practice something or that kind of guy, they like, they don't like him, but they like the funny me. They get, I do pretty good. Oh, good. I make them comfortable.
他们看你的搞笑电影吗，你知道的？对，对，对。我的意思是，我在家里表现得挺好。当我能逗笑他们时我很高兴，因为当我要求他们练习什么的时候，或者我是那种严厉的家伙时，他们不喜欢，但他们喜欢搞笑的我。我表现得还不错。哦，很好。我让他们感到舒适。
And then I definitely try to be funny a lot and try to get funny. laughs. I don't always, always score. Like, I try to take them out of the moves. I think growing up, that was my move, too, when I felt my father about to fucking go nuts on me. Of course, I said a few jokes to lighten them up. I think I do that with the kids, too, when I see him upset about something. I go to the jokes. Do you guys do that? 100%. Adam, who's the disciplinarian then? If you make them laugh, everyone's, I mean, is Jackie the one that's laying down the law, or do you do both? I heard you guys talking about this. You're lighter than Amanda, right?
然后我绝对会努力表现得很有趣，并试图博得笑声。我并不总能成功。比如，我试着把他们从情绪中拉出来。我想在成长过程中，那也是我的应对方式，当我感觉到我父亲快要他妈的对我发疯时。当然，我会说几个笑话来缓和气氛。我想当我看到孩子们为什么事情心烦意乱时，我也会对他们这样做。我会用笑话来化解。你们也会这样吗？百分之百。亚当，那谁是纪律担当呢？如果你让他们笑，每个人都，我是说，是杰琪在立规矩吗，还是你们俩都管？我听你们聊过这个。你比阿曼达更随和，对吧？
I'm lighter, but I would imagine you might be similar to me where you're super, you're the class clown, you're the Joker, but then you can swing all the way to the other side and really get serious if you need to and there's really nothing in between. Oh, yeah, I think I get really fucking nuts where they just scared eyes at me when I'm like, no, you have to know this because right when I start raising my voice. That Jackie would not do, like Amanda would not do that. She covers the whole middle ground and I'm like the bookends. Jackie cuts me off in the middle of that, too, and starts going.
我更随和，但我想你可能和我有点像，你超级，你是班里的活宝，你是小丑，但随后你可以完全转向另一面，如果需要的话会变得非常严肃，而且中间几乎没有任何缓冲。哦，对，我想我有时候会变得非常疯狂，当我开始提高嗓门时，他们只会用惊恐的眼神看着我，因为……杰琪才不会那样做，比如阿曼达就不会那样。她包揽了中间所有的地带，而我就像两端的书挡。杰琪也会在中间打断我，开始说……
She takes a weapon out of your hand, right? You got to, yeah, she's like, they can't understand. The weapon, I guess, is my fucking loud, you know, semi-angry tone all of a sudden. She's just like, stop, stop. You can't, they don't understand when you're doing that. They have to know this, all right? Listen to how loud I am. Yeah, exactly.
她卸下了你手上的武器，对吧？你不得不，是的，她就像，他们听不懂……所谓的武器，我想就是我那他妈的大嗓门，你知道的，突然间半生气的语调。她只是说：停下，停下。你不能这样，他们不懂你为什么这么做。他们必须知道这个，好吧！听听我声音有多大。对，没错。
And then it goes away, and then I'm a kiss-ass most of the time. I like keeping them fucking happy. I like when they're happy and laughing. But I put some pressure on them. Not about, I don't know if you guys have this, but everything I did, I would just go outside and practice and fucking basketball, baseball, even bike riding.
然后那种情绪就消失了，然后大部分时间我又变成了个马屁精。我喜欢让他们开开心心的。我喜欢他们开心和欢笑。但我确实给他们施加了一些压力。不是关于……我不知道你们有没有这种感觉，但我做过的每件事，我都会去外面练习，他妈的篮球、棒球，甚至骑自行车。
I was just like be in my own fucking world, just driving in circles, trying to hop off a curb, trying to pop a wheelie, whatever the fuck that was. And I don't see my kids want to do that as much as me. So I'm like, there's nothing you want to get good at. I do that, that shit.
我当时就像在自己的小世界里，绕着圈子骑车，试图从路缘石上跳过去，试图翘起车头骑行，不管他妈的到底是什么。我看到我的孩子们不像我当年那样想做这些。所以我就会想：没有什么事是你想要练好的吗？我就会做那些破事儿。
And they're just like not, just not what you want us to get good at. We want to get good at what we like, you know? All right. Well, in closure, I have one last question for you. What makes you happiest? In all of these areas of your life, it seems like there's so much harmony
而他们只是不想，只是不想做那些我们想让你练好的事。我们想练我们喜欢的事，你知道的？好吧。那么最后，我有一个最后的问题要问你。什么事最让你开心？在你生活的所有这些领域中，似乎有着如此多的和谐
and everything's kind of cruising, and there's so many things to bring you happiness. I'll bet you'll say family or some garbage like that. And by the way, this is going to be informative. He's looking for something to make him happy. So he's looking for clues, whatever kind of clue. Yeah, I just can't find him. Yeah.
一切都在顺利进行，有那么多事情能带给你快乐。我敢打赌你会说家庭或者诸如此类的废话。顺便说一句，这会很有启发性。他在寻找能让他快乐的东西。所以他在寻找线索，不管是什么线索。对，我就是找不到。对。
If you had to, usually where do you find yourself the most sort of just serene and this is a great day? Well, fuck, I would have to say when shit's going good at home, everything is good. That's true. You know what I mean? When the kids and your wife or your partner are happy and there's nothing else to be concerned about, you're just fucking free to be who you were as a kid, you know? Like, that's when I feel like, shit, I'm making it. a movie. This is great. When I'm fucking making a movie
如果你必须说的话，通常你在哪里会觉得自己最宁静，觉得“今天真是个好日子”？好吧，操，我不得不说，当家里一切顺利时，一切都很好。真的。你知道我的意思吗？当孩子们和你的妻子或伴侣都很开心，没有其他需要担心的事情时，你他妈就自由了，可以做回小时候的自己，你知道吗？就像，那就是我觉得，操，我成功了。在拍电影。这太棒了。当我他妈的在拍电影
and I get a call from home and something's off, I'm like, and I'm fucking lost. I'm lost until that shit gets resolved, right? And you've got to act good and the other actors are joking around and you're kind of like, what? You're a beat behind. And you're looking at your phone because you're like, fuck is this thing going to
接到家里的电话，发现有点不对劲时，我就会想……而且我他妈迷失了。在事情解决之前我都是迷失的，对吧？然后你还得好好演戏，其他演员都在开玩笑，而你却有点像，什么？你慢了半拍。你看着手机，因为你在想，这破事儿什么时候才能
resolve itself? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, you're fucking heartache. Harding for no reason. And then all of a sudden I doubled mine because I now have like an ex-wife, so I want to make sure that Amy's happy and also my partner and every i've got like way too many people i'm worried about her happy now sure sure sure yeah it sounds like a complaint listen i'm a very lucky guy but still yes absolutely no we all are but the depth definitely ups and downs in my own brain i can't i never have a fucking 24 hour
解决？对，对。对，你他妈无缘无故地心痛。然后突然之间我把我的心痛加倍了，因为我现在有了一个前妻，所以我想确保艾米开心，还有我的伴侣，每个人……我有太多需要担心他们开不开心的了，现在。确实，确实，对……听起来像是在抱怨。听着，我是个非常幸运的人，但依然如此，是的，绝对的。不，我们都是，但我自己的脑子里绝对有起有落。我从来没有过一整天24小时
happy day i don't see that ever ever coming my way but i have when i'm working i'm pretty like all right let's all right how about you guys when you're working are you like this is great You know, you kind of like... When the phone is off, because you're working and you're on set and you're in that thing, that is a great space. When you're really in it, I remember, for me, one of my happiest times was when Jason and I were first doing Arrested Development, and so people, you didn't text as much back then.
都开心的日子。我看不出这种日子会有降临到我头上的一天。但我工作的时候，我差不多会想：好吧，让我们……好吧，你们呢？你们工作的时候，会觉得这太棒了吗？你知道的，你有点像……当手机关机时，因为你在工作，你在片场，你在那种状态中，那是一个很棒的空间。当你真正沉浸其中时，我记得对我来说，我最快乐的时光之一就是杰森和我刚开始拍《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）的时候，所以人们，那时候你发短信没那么多。
It was because everybody still had to flip phones. I remember I got a new flip phone. I was so psyched. A two-way pager. A two-way pager thing. We had those... And I just remember, like, you'd go to... you'd go to work, you leave your trailer or whatever your dressing,
那是因为当时每个人都还在用翻盖手机。我记得我拿到了一部新的翻盖手机。我当时兴奋极了。一个双向寻呼机。一个双向寻呼机设备。我们有那种……我只记得，就像，你会去……你会去上班，你离开你的化妆车或者不管什么更衣室，
you'd go on to set and you're on there for like four hours and you're not contacting the outside world and you're in this thing working and you're in it, that is a happy memory for me. But if you know that there's something a little sideways back home, you still can't 100% enjoy it. So staying a little bit ahead at home and making sure that that's all running smoothly
你走到片场，在上面呆上大约四个小时，你不会联系外界，你沉浸在这个东西里工作，你完全投入其中，对我来说这是一段快乐的记忆。但如果你知道家里有点什么小问题，你还是无法百分之百地享受它。所以把家里的事情处理得稍微超前一点，确保一切都在顺利运行
and it will be smooth again tomorrow too because I'm not just, you know, you know i'm doing something proactive to keep it going forward and staying ahead of it i've been trying to do lately yeah my my wife uh when i know i go on tuesday i got a pretty that big scene blah blah uh she'll go okay and then she'll kind of block shit she should not bring shit up to me on a big day oh that's nice that's pretty nice and then yeah that's nice anyways and then yeah i got you run lines with her yeah oh my god all the top And she's good at finding shit that I wasn't going to do in the scene and going like,
而且明天也会再次顺利，因为我不只是，你知道的，你知道我在采取积极主动的措施来让它继续前进并保持领先——我最近一直在试图这样做。对，我的妻子——当我知道周二我有一场挺重要的戏，林林总总的——她会说：好吧。然后她就会把事情挡掉，在大日子里她不会把破事儿抛给我。哦，那太好了，那挺不错的。然后，对，那挺不错的，不管怎样，然后，对，我和她对台词。对，天哪，总是这样。而且她很擅长找出我在这场戏里原本不会注意到的问题，然后说：
well, don't you know what that line means? Oh, that's awesome. She does that for me. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I do it all the time here. You do that with Scotty? Constantly. That's nice.
难道你不知道那句台词是什么意思吗？哦，太棒了。她会为我这样做。对，对。对，我这里一直这么做。你和斯科蒂（Scotty）也这样吗？经常这样。那太好了。
Are you good at memorizing your lines, Adam? Not too good. How about you? No. Jason's the best in the biz, the best of all time. That's a fucking TV shit. That's a TV shit. Yeah.
亚当，你擅长背台词吗？不太擅长。你呢？不擅长。杰森是业内最棒的，史上最棒的。那是电视圈的破事儿。那是电视圈的破事儿。对。
He's fucking unbelievable. I'm surprised at Saturday Night Live. Didn't kind of grind that in on you. Or were you just looking at the cards the whole time? Both. They tell you two, right? I would do the panic thing like before Letterman. I remember I did this shit on Weekend Update where I did costumes, crazy, I'm crazy pickle arm and all this shit.
他他妈的太不可思议了。我很惊讶《周六夜现场》没有把这个本事刻进你的骨子里。还是说你全程都在看提词卡？两者都有。他们会告诉你两个，对吧？我会在像上莱特曼（Letterman）节目之前产生恐慌感。我记得我在“周末更新”（Weekend Update）里做过这破事儿，我穿着戏服，疯狂的泡菜手臂还有所有这些破事儿。
And I had to do this thing where I was, I'm crazy under the desk guy. So I remember in my head, I went, when you're crazy under the desk guy, there's no cue cards because you're going under the desk and you got to remember your shit. And I remember I fucking live. I went under my desk and it was like, my head's going, holy shit, there's no fucking Q cards. You're in trouble, man. And I think I've remembered most of them and got it done. But no, I like knowing the Q cards were around.
我必须演这样一个角色：我是那个疯狂的桌子底下的人。所以我记得我在脑子里想过，当你演疯狂的桌子底下的人时，是没有提词卡的，因为你要钻到桌子底下，你必须记住你他妈的台词。我记得我他妈在直播时。我钻到了桌子底下，当时我的脑子在想：天哪，他妈的没有提词卡。你惹上麻烦了，伙计。我想我大部分都记住了，并且完成了。不过，不，我还是喜欢周围有提词卡。
You were tight with Wally, right? Was Wally doing Q cards back then? I know, Wally. He just texted me out of the blue the other day. Oh, yeah. He's doing well. He's got fucking some other business he's doing right now. Yeah, I don't know.
你跟沃利（Wally）很熟，对吧？沃利那时候还在做提词卡吗？我知道，沃利。前几天他莫名其妙地给我发了条短信。哦，对。他过得很好。他现在在搞他妈的别的生意。对，我不知道。
He's, yeah. I haven't heard from him years. but Wally was the guy, the Q-Cardia. He's got an amusement park now. I think he just started an amusement park. What is worth, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, John Candy's working there.
他，对。我好几年没听到他的消息了。不过沃利就是那个人，提词卡大师。他现在开了一家游乐园。我想他刚刚开了一家游乐园。值得吗，对吧？对，对，对。哦，约翰·坎迪（John Candy）在那里工作。
It's nice. Adam, you're incredibly generous to give us all this time. Thank you for saying yes to doing the show in the first place. Thank you for asking me, guys. We love you. Congratulations on your show. It's a great thing you're doing it, getting to hang out all the time together and you've been great guys. We're pretty lucky.
太好了。亚当，你抽出这么多时间给我们，真是太慷慨了。谢谢你一开始答应来做这个节目。谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。我们爱你。恭喜你们的节目。你们在做一件伟大的事，能一直聚在一起闲逛，而且你们一直是好样的。我们挺幸运的。
We're very appreciative. So looking forward to seeing on the golf course tomorrow. We'll be there probably about 830. We're going to warm up first. I know you don't like to warm up, but we will worm up. Right, right on, man. All right, right on, man. All right, we love you.
我们非常感激。非常期待明天在高尔夫球场见面。我们大概8点30分到。我们要先热身。我知道你不喜欢热身，但我们会热身的。好样的，伙计。好样的，伙计。好样的，伙计。好吧，我们爱你。
Say hi to your family. Love you, pal. You too. Thanks, buddy. Good to see you guys. Okay, bye, pal. All right, later, guys. Oh, he's fantastic.
代我向你家人问好。爱你，老兄。你也是。谢谢，伙计。很高兴见到你们。好的，再见，老兄。回头见，伙计们。哦，他太棒了。
What a good, decent guy. It's so engaging. Like, I could listen to him talk for hours. And by the way, how he's talking about all that anxiety that he has. I'm like, yeah, I totally get that. I relate. Yeah, he stayed so human when he's had many opportunities probably not to. He's able to stay very loyal to him.
真是个好人，正派的人。太有吸引力了。比如，我可以听他讲几个小时的话。顺便说一句，他谈到自己所有的那种焦虑时。我心想，是的，我完全理解。我很有共鸣。是的，在有很多机会可以不这么做的时候，他依然保持着如此人性化的一面。他能够对
his friends. He's also putting up a great product. He's got his family with him. He's just been so smart the way he's kind of put all these pieces that are available to him into a certain direction that I would imagine perpetuate so much happiness for him and so many people that are close to him and obviously his audience as well. He's a good human being. Yeah. Yeah. He's a well-rounded guy. He's got a sort of happy life. And for me anyway, I like looking at the people who are having a happy life Because it's not defined by what they do, but it's defined by so many other things, starting with family. And what they do with the things that are available to them in their life, whether it be, you know, really expensive, nice things or not. What you do with what you've got, I think, is a good test.
他的朋友们保持极大的忠诚。他也拿出了很棒的产品。他的家人陪伴在他身边。他真的很聪明，把所有这些唾手可得的碎片以某种方向拼凑在一起，我想这会为他、为他身边亲近的人以及他的观众带来数不尽的快乐。他是个好人。对。是的。他是个全面的人。他有着某种快乐的生活。不管怎样，对我来说，我喜欢看着那些过着快乐生活的人，因为这并不是由他们做什么决定的，而是由许多其他事情决定的，从家庭开始。以及他们如何利用生活中唾手可得的东西，无论是非常昂贵、美好的东西还是别的什么。我认为，你如何对待你所拥有的东西，是一个很好的考验。
Yeah. Thank you, too, Adam, for joining us. That was, that was a great one. I like that. He better take us golfing. He better take us golfing. And thank you, listener, for joining us for another hour of Smartless. Oh.
是的。也谢谢你，亚当，加入我们。那期节目太棒了。我很喜欢。他最好带我们去打高尔夫。他最好带我们去打高尔夫。也谢谢听众朋友们加入我们，度过了又一个小时的“聪明笨蛋”（Smartless）。哦。
Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。